it just wasn't working with the
corporate job I kind of came home from
work the one day and said we've got to
figure something out here because I
can't wait for someone else's permission
to come home and look after my family
said right this is what I want to do
we'll get married I'll quit my job I'll
join the academy let's go almost
immediately we found out we were
pregnant with Quinn so talk about the
pressure bin on 40 Grand a month
turnover of about how much profit we
will be comfortably over 12 this month
what I want to talk to you about is how
you've taken a small pot of money and
recycled it using the bar refurbatory
Finance strategy because that's just
amazing I honestly thought I'd invented
the money printer because I was using
the same money to buy other properties
and then cash flowing a grand each as
you've got the fast pound with the rent
to rent but then you've also got the
slow pound with the brrs it's been hands
down the best 12 months of my life I can
say that easily
foreign
and turning over crazy amounts of money
in property 40 Grand a month turnover
about how much profit we will be
comfortably over 12 this month and going
forward I hope that that would be a slow
month and you've now got what 10 10
properties we'll have 12 online as of
this month 14 online as of next and uh
more in the pipeline what I want to talk
to you about a lot is how you've taken a
small pot of money and recycled it using
the buy refurbishery Finance strategy
because that's just amazing I'm really
excited about people actually growing
wealth and you're doing that you've got
the slow pound you've got the fast pound
so talk to me about how did this all
start a good few years ago now before we
had crossed paths uh I had done a small
development kind of just a Fix and Flip
and I had some money lying around from
that and decided I needed to find out
what the best way to invest that was and
started Googling started going down
YouTube rabbit holes found yourself back
in 2018 that would have been so I went
to one of your training courses and I
had in mind that I thought a um HMO
might be the road to go down and then I
start to find out the restrictions that
were in place around our area but it was
really when people first started
mentioning service accommodation so I
came away from the course thinking well
I think I want to give that a go I can
start with a smaller amount of money but
get similar kind of returns and yeah
started shopping around found a place in
Worcester that actually fit the bill
quite well needed some work I managed to
get some outside investment from a
family member who business partnered
with me on that one and within six
months we had
um refinanced that took our original
investment out and we're making I'd say
between the Grand and a grand and a half
month profit on that and what was that
was that just a purchase or was that
about to rent no that was a straight
purchase you just bought it and rented
out in service accommodation that's
right yeah afterwards refurbed it added
some value and then took our initial
investment straight back out so you
combined the buy refurbish with the
service accommodation strategy that's
exactly right do you have any regular
tenants on AST contracts or all of your
10 it's guests um they are all guests
now I had tried with uh regular tenants
previously and I can tell you now I find
the service accommodation guests far
less hassle to deal with than regular
tenants I went into an estate agency I
said to them I was looking to buy
properties to do a service accommodation
I was actually in Birmingham at the time
and they said to me oh service
accommodation short stay let's is a
nightmare to manage and I said well you
need systems and processes but there's
it's way more cash flow and not only to
wear more cash flow but the tenants are
guests so they don't have the right so
you don't have to worry about evictions
and stuff and he was just like like
really hated really hostile towards the
the strategy which really surprised me
well we built a business around it and
at the end of the day that's what it is
it comes with the same headaches you
would get I guess with a normal business
dealing with customers and customer
service and things but yeah it's not
easy it's not necessarily
straightforward but it's extremely
lucrative if you do it right and the
cash flow can be amazing and yeah you've
just got to run it professionally I
suppose I've seen some of your
properties your Penthouse in Birmingham
is amazing I've been trying to book
there for months but it's so fully
booked yes well actually uh I've just
stayed there for the first time myself
for my wife's first wedding anniversary
so oh beautiful I'd love to have you
there but I've had trouble getting in
myself yeah it's not easy when you've
got properties so sometimes I've had a
lot of Academy members as well that have
bought a property on the beach or
something they've said we'll rent it out
a short stay let's but then whenever we
want we'll stay there and then three
years later I'm like have you been there
yet no it's just fully booked yeah so so
your Fix and Flip which was prior to any
training you did with me prior to being
on the academy yeah talk me through that
how much do you buy that for the figures
on that were we bought I bought it for I
think
135 at the time put uh chipped away at
it gradually fixed it up and then I
think we got it uh refinanced at uh 170
so I had roughly about 40 000 pounds
ready to to invest yeah and that was
what went into our first um service
accommodation I actually put the offer
on the place got accepted and then
someone matched it with a cash offer so
the estate agent kept him back and said
look they want to do the business with
you but can you do it cash so I turned
around to uh my family and said look I'm
going to refinance this money out give
me six months I'll give it you back with
interest oh and by the way I'm gonna let
it buy the night and I think they
thought I was nuts but I am extremely
blessed to come from a very very
supportive family so I think even though
they didn't necessarily see what I saw
at that time they backed me and
everything I said about it um we pulled
off and got the money back out and then
we recycled that into the next service
accommodation apartment and so at that
point I honestly thought I'd invented
the money printer because I was using
the same money to buy other properties
and then cash flowing a grand each a
grand and a half each property and that
worked amazing for us as a business
until covid things obviously slowed down
with what was going on there um we kept
the lights on WE ticked over but it was
more like regular
um
um tenanted money coming in rather than
what why did things slow down over
covert because property Market was still
open it was just just getting guests
through the door so obviously yeah that
was tough yeah oh God I thought you
meant the buying process no no no well
funny enough we carried on buying right
but for doing fix and flips at that time
so that was kind of another area of the
business we we continued to grow despite
what was going on there but in terms of
a um yeah a kind of a tourist-led
business things obviously yeah ground to
a bit of a hole Yeah well Airbnb was
closed booking.com was closed you
literally had to completely change your
model I mean we were looking at the time
that there was still solicitors still
had to try cases and there was other
things that were going on so we did like
I said we kept the lights on so to speak
we didn't lose money but uh yeah that
led me to basically rather than keep my
eyes on the property um growing a
property business I kind of focused on
my corporate career instead and carried
on with that
um and yeah we came out of the other
side of covid and things started to
cycle back up I was so busy with my uh
regular job at the time what was that I
was account management so kind of sales
really yeah and once things started to
cycle back up I'd propose to my now wife
so if you you've just met with Quinn we
were planning on getting married this
August we would have just gone past what
was supposed to be our first wedding
anniversary but unfortunately we had
some bad news about uh family members
health so we made the call right we just
got to get this done quickly so we kind
of went to arrange a full-scale wedding
in the space of three months and it just
wasn't working with the corporate job
and I wasn't able to
um put the time in that I needed at home
and with the other things that were
going on in order to make that happen
really and I couldn't leave Sophie on
her own to do it so I kind of came home
from work the one day and said we've got
to figure something out here because I
can't wait for someone else's permission
to come home and look after my family so
revisit the academy spoke to some of
your guys said right this is what I want
to do we'll get married I'll quit my job
I'll join the academy and let's go so
basically kind of a little bit on a
prayer and a bit of faith and the
support of Sophie and lots of other
things that's what happened
um so it got back from our honeymoon did
the first Academy training just over a
year ago now in September and almost
immediately we found out we were
pregnant with Quinn
so talk about the the pressure bin on
just no job no income new family new
house all this stuff and uh you know
just had to really decide to make it
work for the Academy how did you justify
investing so much in your education and
networking training when you're on such
you know you've got the wedding cost
coming up you you're quitting your job
how do you how did you justify that
because I just did know in my heart that
it was what we needed to do in order to
have the freedom to
um look after each other be a family and
ultimately kind of live the kind of life
that we wanted as well I think I had it
in there somewhere that I knew that I
had to kind of um chart my own course
basically
um and again like I say with the support
that Sophie gave me I think that when I
was trying to explain rent to rent to
people this is what we're going to do
we're going to start getting money in
straight away the service accommodation
that we've done with buying places
before we're going to do that we're
going to rent it off a landlords and
um see if we can get cash flow from that
and you are met with a level of
skepticism from people but also again I
have to say the support that I had
around me I think people just
um believed in me to get it done so uh
off we went really and then a few months
down the line no money coming in still
working on the first still waiting for
it to come through get to near enough
Christmas before we get our first one
online and then things just really took
off from there all of a sudden it just
started to snowball really and more
started coming through to us we started
working quicker through them getting
them online so then we had the first one
then the penthouse then we started
working in development in the jewelry
quarter in Birmingham where we have four
luxury properties there now that we have
on service accommodation from there
really uh landlords and investors
started to come to us to ask if we could
help with their property so we've worked
out some really interesting strategies
to make the most out of them especially
with the market at the minute landlords
are having to reach the end of their
fixed term are finding all of a sudden
they're potentially underwater so what
can they be doing instead well we'll
come in and Sophie is in charge of kind
of the um the staging and the the
creative so she'll come in she'll put a
move ball together in a plant out we can
make this kind of a boutique or a luxury
property and then if we get the
handshake from them in in icon with the
team and we'll get it up and running
Within the space of a few weeks already
in cash flowing almost immediately the
thing I love about your business model
is you've got the fast pound with the
rent to rent which is given quick
immediate cash flow but then you've also
got the slow pound with the brrs yeah
which obviously takes time yes but it's
got to buy a to buy a property and to
refurb it refinance it the whole process
is quite slow what do you think you're
better at are you better at Buy
refurbished refinance or service
accommodation management I think that we
have drilled down so much on the finer
points of the surface accommodation
business and to be honest with you it's
amazing that we can do it together it's
something we're actually both really
passionate about and we love that as a
business brrr it's nice to see the end
result and it's certainly nice to see
the money hit the bank but it can be a
grind we're working on quite a big
project at the minute that we've worked
with them some investors on and there's
been some bumps in the road on that
let's say it started off well in terms
of tailed off a touch but there always
is yeah yeah exactly hiccups um yeah
funnily enough as well whenever me and
Sophie sit down to start a new project
that we kind of have this um talk that
we always have is like expect the
problems we know this is going to be
hard there's no point in US learning to
each other that this is difficult right
now we know we're going to do something
difficult so figure it out let's go
through it and what was it about that
property that attracted you to buy it to
be totally honest with you it's uh our
family home at the minute so I saw the
potential for us to um not only uh
hopefully make some money back for some
investors who have come on board with us
not only take some money out for
ourselves but then also we can kind of
microwave what we want and create a
space to grow our family and as long as
every time you spend a pound you're
adding three pounds worth of value oh I
mean I put the a very stringent investor
pack based on actually the very first
training that we uh we did with them
yourself uh in my view it was why we
bought the property it was kind of it
was airtight really we the numbers
really stacked up it was a deal that
worked
um every day of the week so why not make
the most of it for ourselves yeah so
what would you say is your strongest
reason for this then because you've put
you put your neck on the line quitting
your job baby on the way it started off
um with my family for sure started off
with I wanted to be there for Sophie and
um considering me to add some of the
health concerns in the family to be
available for that and then it started
then it became more about my family
because then Quinn came into the picture
and we knew we were expecting our first
and I had to make something of it uh if
not for that alone but along the way too
we bought other family members into what
we're doing so my dad was actually one
of my First Investors that we business
partnered with them the first property
uh either the family members now that
have invested in the service
accommodation business that are making a
handsome cash flow per month and um yeah
there's other people that we've been
able to help around us and ultimately it
means that I can take whatever time I
need to go and get the vaccinations with
Quinn or I can take this appointment or
so if you can go do this during the week
and I can be at home with the baby which
is where I want to be right now uh when
it's running a normal life and having a
business and having a job you know job
takes up a lot of time yeah in fact to
be totally honest with you I would take
my hat off to people that managed to
have a family and then leave the house
at 8 and get back six and still have the
energy to do anything else outside of
that yeah it's hard somebody the right
decision and quit your job a million
percent we've never looked back in fact
like I say we've just had our first
wedding anniversary and it's the time
you take to reflect really so a year ago
we just got married honeymoon Academy
and we look at kind of the dozen or so
properties that we've got online the
construction projects that we've
accomplished but also the stuff that
we've done ourselves in the time we've
been able to put into our relationship
the traveling you know having the baby
and the time we spent with our family as
well all of that it's been hands down
the best 12 months of my life I can say
that easily what I've been some of the
biggest learning points over the last 12
months of your Mac because you've been
in property a little while now you came
on my first course I think the beginning
of 2018 went away did a few bits and
Bobs yeah but then it was really just
2022 and the last 12 months you've
you've absolutely had exponential growth
yeah not just your business but also
your profits what were you making like
18 months ago 18 months here in property
that's probably a bad time to ask
because of the pandemic before the
pandemic we were are making probably
about three grand ish per month okay we
have two properties yeah which was you
know handy a lot of people be very happy
with that I certainly was um there were
two like brrs that you bought that's it
yeah yeah and then test accommodation
them after the pandemic they started to
tip back up I'd say maybe Grand maybe
Grand and a half because we had a
management company management because I
was working full-time and then after
that with each property that we've added
on we've aimed to bring kind of let's
say ground and a half to our cash flow
per month for example the penthouse that
you bought before last month that made
us 2 700 pounds on its own wow so what
would you say the last 12 months biggest
learning points you've just got to be
relentless I think the position that we
put ourselves in was that there was no
other option there was no fallback and
what am I going to do about
um you know our son or our family if I
don't make this work so just no one
cares work harder and just go and go and
go and eventually we just always found a
way think that we found levels that we
could reach and just like Grit
termination that um we didn't know we
could reach but I think you can't do it
otherwise what I've been some of the
hardest points over the last 12 months
the toughest spot for me was for sure
when we knew that we were pregnant with
Quinn
but
um we hadn't got that first property
online and I was working really hard to
get that done we were all pulling in the
same direction the landlord wanted to
work the agent wanted to work the deal
Source wanted to make it work but
because there were so many I guess chefs
in the kitchen this guy was on holiday
so this Gotta Wait for two weeks and
this and this and the process that I was
hoping would take like a fortnight ended
up taking six seven weeks until we
finally got there and that became
stressful then because you know that it
could potentially fall out of bed at any
minute as well so if I just spent a
month working on something that we're
not going to get quite finished but yeah
once we got there in terms of management
then so you've got at the moment 10
properties is about to become 14. it's
10 online
um two that we're just putting the
finishing touches on that will be coming
available in the next uh two weeks and
then deals done on another two that
we'll be moving straight on to once
these projects are completed so how are
you managing those properties then is
that I mean you said you know your wife
helps a lot with that yes but how does
that work what does that look like if
you've got cleaners have you got
automation things have you employed
somebody just management companies so
we've got we have got a fantastic
um cleaning team
um that um we kind of sub contract that
out and then um our guy that manages
that company Chris has got his own team
there and they do a fantastic job of
managing all Linens and cleans and we've
systemized it that we've got a complete
hands-off approach when it comes to that
unless there's an issue that needs
dealing with and then we've got a really
good CRM that we use to manage all the
bookings coming through and what have
you and then we've actually just signed
and we'll be moving today into some
offices in the jewelry course oh yeah
right and we are building a team out
around that so we've got um a young girl
that's come on board who's uh fantastic
who's taking care of kind of some of the
customer service issues getting back to
guests and dealing with bits and pieces
on the ground while I'm away doing doing
business generating activities hopefully
and then
um yeah we've got kind of a bit of a
team that's going around the the
Worcester side of the business as well
so yeah we're actively recruiting and
hiring hiring and building you're going
to have like an office staff yeah we've
got office staff
um and yeah like a lot of other
subcontractors why do you need all that
stuff just to manage like the properties
that you've got there's only so much
that you can do on your own I can't then
grow the business anymore I can't be
putting proposals in front of investors
or talking to people about the next
projects that we've got going when I'm
constantly putting legs on sofas because
they're broken a property or whatever
else so the easiest way for me to buy
back my time was to hire someone in to
do those roles and the easiest thing
straight away to to get people on are
kind of some of their maintenance issues
that I was dealing with myself up until
now while the customer service stuff in
fact to be totally honest with you the
handyman work and the customer service
there's better people out there than
that than me so right by all means you
guys go take a look at that and I'll
I'll focus on growing the business yeah
how many properties do you think that
you because you've got home you're
setting up a whole management arm as
well right yes to manage other people's
problems so hence why you're needing an
office and a staff that's right yeah so
big shout out to high living estate
actually
they do deal sourcing in Birmingham and
their office is just around the corner
from us they've become good friends with
us over the last 12 months and they've
also been on winners on a Wednesday yes
we won the Academy yeah they don't know
this so the first time they'll be
hearing this their winners on a
Wednesday was the one that I showed
Sophie before I said I want to join the
academy wow so can we join up and then
after that they were one of the first
calls I made to kind of start networking
within the academy it happens all the
time yeah people will say oh I watched
so-and-so's winners on a Wednesday and
then join the academy and then they end
up doing business imagine all the people
that will watch this video and then
they'll end up being part of the
community doing business with you well
well I hope they do and I'd love to pay
that forward and help that the
inspiration and the help and the support
we got from Charlotte and shy and other
members of The Academy as well I'd love
people to uh come and approach me and uh
really interesting though Nile how the
community within the property space
certainly within within our property
space is very much about helping other
people because normally if you're you're
from the corporate background in the
corporate world or most professions if
you want to be successful people that
have been in the business a few years
will try and keep you down yeah and
they'll say oh it's really difficult oh
no you need to prove you're worth but in
this community it's like someone new
will be like right I want to get started
I don't got any deals and people that
are
six months six years ahead we'll pull
them up give them a leggy what a
beautiful thing that is yeah without a
doubt I have often said it to the people
that have asked me about
um joining the Academy I would pay the
money over again just for the network
alone outside of the training you put a
message in that group chat I asked a
question the other day about getting a
particular bit of support on something
I'm inundated my phone blows up with
people messaging me privately so I can
help with this I can help with that I
can't tell you the amount of favors I've
called in from people on the academy and
again it's something that we like to try
and pay forward to so yeah we try that's
what it's about being I call it givers
gain you know you you give your tax you
don't just come into the community
you give what you can you give of
yourself and then and then you take a
little and as time's gone on we've kind
of developed our expertise in the
service accommodation stuff and
especially the premium high-end the
staging and getting those kind of 100
nights up to 250 to 300 pound a night
and making small tweaks in your approach
to get that done and that goes straight
to the bottom line anything additional
you make in in Revenue when it becomes
your price per night you basically put
straight in your pocket so people have
come to us with help with that how do we
do it and um yeah for Academy members
especially we're always happy to assist
what would you say is the easiest way if
someone was like brand new into the
community into the space and they didn't
have a big pot of money yeah what do you
think the quickest and easiest fastest
way is to get your foot in the door the
best way I've seen people gain traction
when they're coming in completely cold
and without any money at all is to
um go and do some deal sourcing yeah
trying some money in the bank from that
say you sell three four deals five grand
to play with and that's enough money to
seed you your first one or two bed
that's accommodation apartment and off
you go and on the academy it is
difficult to sell deals no it isn't no
especially the deals are good deals yeah
yeah and you can get them checked out
get embedded and then once you've got a
bit of money then what then partner with
somebody or put it into a rental brand
or service accommodation I mean I mean
I'm biased about it because I think
we've since so much successful service
accommodation and I know that if you do
it right there's a lot of money to be
made in it but yeah I think just going
straight for a rent to rent then if you
look into cash flow and all of a sudden
that relieves a bit of the pressure so
you can um then if you've got a grand
and a half maybe you should be a second
one three grand per month coming in
steady cash flow
um into your pocket you can kind of lift
your head up a little bit and think
right where do I want to be longer term
then and start planning six months at a
time rather than the thing is now people
will spend 40 years working on a job for
two grand a month imagine if someone
just said you know what I'm going to
follow exactly what Naja said I'm going
to try and sell three Deals get a six
grand in my account get two or three
rent to rent how long is that going to
take yeah a month two months six months
if you go on a mission or so I'm just
gonna follow that advice by the time
you've achieved that and it might be six
days six weeks six months depending on
how fast you're on the support that
you've got you don't need a job anymore
we'll put it this way within the space
of
um 12 months we managed to I know we had
a bit of a it wasn't a complete old
start but we went from a business that
was bringing maybe a couple of grand a
month to yeah no we're doing north of 40
Grand per month now uh this month we'll
do comfortably 12 Grand profit um I'm
expecting that with what we've got going
forward now to
um pick up considerably as well so we've
kind of got um
a goal where we want to reach by the end
of the year it's a bit of a lofty Target
but I think that we're actually doing it
we want to be a million pound turnover
business
um within this um calendar month so we
want to be doing at least um six figure
months uh regularly that's from when I I
intend to be uh up there by November
that's crazy good where do you get like
your furniture and stuff from yeah do
you know I think that you can get stuff
that looks really high quality without
spending an arm and leg on it it's
surface accommodation so there is going
to be an element of wear and tear you
don't want to be spending three grand on
a sofa that's going to take 12 weeks to
come from a specific manufacturer prices
like dial places like dunelm is a good
one as well they do unique sets that you
know if you don't want to just spend
Bottom Dollar on it and you just look a
little bit um to kind of the the
mid-range stuff there you can get some
really attractive looking stuff did you
go to IKEA I do but for finishing
touches the one thing that I do say to
our investors I say look this is
Birmingham this is where you're looking
to invest there's literally it says
thousands of airbnbs here if you want it
on the top one or two pages no one's
ever going to find you and you're going
to be in a race to the bottom to try and
drop price to just try and fill your
occupancy and if you scroll through they
all look exactly the same and I can tell
you the name of each one of these bits
of Ikea furniture from the amount of
times I've been around the shop and seen
them myself so don't go in and do the
same as everyone else you need it's a
crowded Market you can stand apart if
you do the right things so what about
Facebook Marketplace I have not used it
too much myself I know people that have
had some success with it we use that a
lot yeah really so could you know what
happens people buy a sofa and it will be
no warranty or anything like that and
then after a month the services have
changed they'll move out or something
will happen and they put like a three
grand sofa then they'll just sell it for
a brand and just yeah that's that's
interesting thought actually I think I
should probably revisit that and you
write about making it different it's got
to pop hasn't it yeah without a doubt um
you'll be scrolling through and uh
you'll see the same gray kind of looking
furniture all the way down but to
maximize your engagement even if people
can't necessarily really afford to stay
at your place it's like how people kind
of window shop on right move you'll get
people clicking on an interesting
looking property and have a scroll for
your photos and Airbnb registers that
engagement and that will give you a
little boost on the algorithm as well so
making it look a little bit a bit of
Shazam yeah yeah without a doubt yeah so
people look at it it's almost like you
know Airbnb porn yeah exactly just look
at it ah look at that that's beautiful
isn't it yeah I mean there's various uh
algorithm hacks that we've picked up
over time and that we use to get you
boosted from when you first put your
property online to getting you in that
top 10 as you you scroll down on Airbnb
and it is about
um number one they um push hard to make
sure that your customer service is on
point so your reviews and your comments
but also your calendar have been full
and other types of Engagement too so you
having a property that looks different
looks
um Chic and is interesting people
clicking on that um really helps have
you had any guests
that have not paid or have been a
nightmare you've had to go and get them
out physically once oh tell me did you
have to literally go up turn up yourself
oh I didn't turn up myself
no I didn't tell my wife got help them
if she had a gun no send someone with a
much more level head who just had Kieran
from the academy oh you didn't send
Kieran I got on the phone security again
if you don't know Kieran who's been on
winners on a Wednesday and you would not
wanna you wanna fight him would you no
no and to be honest with you as well he
was so professional and good he
convinced me to let these guys actually
stay in the flat what's not that bad for
them yeah so he's a compassionate killer
he is he is I doubt without a doubt so
these guys had um it turns out they were
filming a rap video but I saw them
running around in the corridor oh please
the police had been called up to um the
apartment so I saw this going on spoke
to Kieran he went round uh and had a
word with them and because they'd
actually I think they've rented out
equipment to film in the penthouse they
paid the stay the guy's like look please
come just pay some more money I'll get
rid of all of these extras that are
causing a scene if I can just stay the
evening and carrying off your phone to
me and said no I think these are good
guys you know Kieran would have joined
in he'd be like I'm gonna be in the rap
video oh yeah it was uh it was it turned
out to be quite funny so hang on hang on
hang on I asked you right what's the
worst experience if you ever had to kick
anybody out and you tell me some great
story about some rappers feel that
sounds like a cool guest I'll be I'll be
up for that what we um it's very very
important to um investors and landlords
when we're doing rent to rents that they
have confidence that it isn't going to
be used as a party pad and we have got a
few different ways that we're able to
deter that from happening and we give a
warning shot in our welcome message as
well about the the consequences of
having a party there and you will be
escorted off by security and you will
pay for their time to do that we can
wrap everything up with them ring
doorbells we've got uh what's called a
minute device that listens out for
decibels inside the property so
generally speaking we're really really
tight I'm making sure that doesn't
happen in the first place so that we
don't have to say that
that is so important because if you have
parties not only can It Crush the place
it can also if it's a rent to make your
landlord can certainly say you're in
breaching you can you can ruin the
property you're going to get all kinds
of bad reviews you can have neighbors
trying it can ruin things so having
those things in place not only is it
going to protect your business but also
you can use it I know you will already
as a sales technique yeah so when you're
trying to get landlords to give you
their properties and they go oh I'm not
sure I don't want parties and all I've
had a bad experience you can go hang on
a minute we've got this implies this
implies this implies this in place these
are the measures and checks that we take
and it just installs so much trust which
makes it so much easier to get the deal
in the first place yeah I definitely
think so it's our refresh anyway but we
want to be as transparent as possible
and we will say to landlords um if we're
in breach of contract you can kick us
out and we've got to be gone within uh
within a matter of days not a matter of
months like a regular tenant so if
there's something going on at the
property that you're not comfortable
with and it breaches the contract by all
means service I noticed and I'll get out
because I haven't done right by you in
in allowing that to happen yeah so um we
tell them that they are welcome to kick
us out if we do breach you don't pay the
rent or if you breach the contract which
then puts the onus on us to deliver like
a stellar service and make sure that
we're on top of issues that arise with
guests and things what are you most
excited about good question because we
kind of set accomplished everything that
we set out to achieve 12 months ago and
then we've had to kind of start with a
blank slate really and say where do we
want the business to go in the next two
years five years where do we see it
going so in terms of what we're excited
about we've got some big plans in
expanding the current service
accommodation business I think that
longer term and I say longer term that
six six to 12 months we would be
interested in looking at apart hotels
and working with investors to work on
say a block of Apartments rather than
doing them one at a time or in
developments where we're just dealing
with a smaller area so that's something
we want to seriously move into at the
start next year and we want to start
developing our portfolio for the
properties that we actually own as well
we spent so much time sorry this year on
this side of the business once we get
our br are through and the cash back out
of that
um we're seeing some of the people do
some amazing things up North with
properties you know what I'll be doing
if I was you as well you're recycling
your cash really good and you've got
your little pot of cash buy a house
refurb it refinance it get your pop back
keep the house for free do it again do
it again do it again what I would be
doing as well is I would be using your
experience and your track record that
you've got and bringing in more
investors yeah to grow your development
business yeah your bra side of things
and I'll be doing slightly bigger deals
on the brr side of things as well yeah
that's what we've got in mind to be
honest with you and that's it that
that's next that's next 12 months next
time as weather scale in your service
accommodation and you and your rent to
rent yes yeah and that again that brings
us back to why we started taking on a
team in the first place so that I don't
have to I can work this expression on
the business not in the business and the
team gives you credibility because if
you've got if you're trying to get money
from investors and do things and you say
look this is our offices we've got staff
there nine to five it just as little
extra level of credence I think yeah I
think it's a good thing yeah thank you
what's it been like working with me then
over the year oh fantastic
I mean it's been like I keep saying but
such an adventure over the last 12
months and yeah we've I've just had so
much fun along the way as well and yeah
it's just amazing to look back and we've
had some real moments yeah I said yeah
yeah we have I mean I remember saying to
you you need to stand up and pitch for
investment do you remember that dinner
yeah stand up man yeah you're saying do
you know any investors I'm like yep 300
investors this time this place stand up
pitch that was it yeah shout out to your
wife wife's name Sophie Sophie I know
she's massively been an integral part of
the business it I mean literally we are
such a team together it just literally
wouldn't happen without both of us uh on
the numbers guy I push things around on
the spreadsheets but she comes in with
the vision for the properties and
basically lays it out in front of me and
then it's my job to try and go and make
it happen really who do you want to see
on Wednesday that's not been on yet
because there's loads of people I could
like we can we can pull do you know what
you say that I'm actually the the kind
of group of people that start the
academy at the same time as me I'm
almost the last one to go on that's
doing uh really well you've had Finn
you've had Billy you've had Adam hindley
Adriana you've had on high living were
just um just before me as well yeah it's
all the people that I started out with
and we're all like what do you think of
that what do you think of the success
rate on the academy is it not a bit nuts
I just don't know how anyone can
question it given that fact and like me
speaking from the inside there's just a
list of names that we all started at
literally the same time and out of all
of them I'm the last one to come on here
and it's not even just like a little bit
as well it's not even like modest like
you know they're financially free and
they're like you know they're all
absolutely smashing yeah like 40 50 60
like money I think that this is why it's
so good to do these things because it's
the type of money that people don't
realize you could be making at 23 24
years of age until you see someone else
start from scratch go ahead and do it
and then like they're all so they're
just great people they're also
personable like they're just great to
get on
23 Charlotte's 23 yeah Finn was 19 or
something like that when he started the
academy yeah and just you think like wow
if they can do it just why can't I you
know and then yeah it just breaks your
reality when you see other people it
does and also who you're around is who
you become if you're around winners
you'll be a winner if you're around
you'll be a loser that's just that's
just the basics of it so I'm really glad
you're doing the academy yeah and I'm
I'm really pleased with your success I
love that you've got the different
things going on with the bras the
service combination now the management
I'm going to leave your Instagram bio
and everything in the link where are you
at on Instagram uh living out at Windows
we'll put that in the description and um
yeah what we're interested in people
reaching out to us if they uh would like
to invest in bras with us it's something
I've said be looking at something a bit
more ambitious in the coming months um
if they're a landlord that is struggling
with their property at the minute that
is not making the money
with the interest rates yeah that's
exactly what we're seeing our business
growing and to an extent if there's
landlords out there that want to get in
touch with us that want to make a bit
more of their property and would like to
see kind of um premium level incomes
coming from that and just anyone that
needs any help from the academy get in
touch as well we'll always do our level
best to give you pointers and and uh and
I'll tell you something interesting as
well uh Nile you came down I think it
was the one pound crash course yes in 20
beginning of 2018. and you did a lot
from that yeah so what would you say to
someone watching this this book today's
holiday from work to go down and do it
yeah yeah and that was in Birmingham
right yes in Birmingham yeah so what
would you say to someone that's one
click away right now because in the
description there's the crash course
it's live right now in Birmingham that's
thinking should I spend a day with
Samuel at the one pound crash course you
did pretty well off of it before even
joining the academy what would you say
to somebody
um if you're seriously considering
investing and you look at the return on
investment you can get from the spending
of a pound and a day or two out of your
life like infinite infinite Returns on
returns on invest investment like what
would be stopping you I don't think
you're serious about investing if that
would be a stopper to you actually yeah
and then sure when you're at the crash
course if you want to invest in further
education mentoring whatever it is
amazing but if at least come to the one
pound loss at least just spend a day
having your eyes open to what's possible
and seeing the different strategies in
motion and meeting a bunch of positive
people and how many people from the
academy go down and crew I mean there's
people that we've mentioned already I
know Billy Kieran have all done Billy's
done well yeah Billy fantastic again
Billy another one that started to send
roughly the same time as me as well yeah
property millionaire yeah yeah and uh
they'll be there so you can ask them
about their experiences and and get
direct answers straight from the horse's
mouth so yeah well now thank you for
coming on the show yeah and thanks for
having me I look forward to seeing your
next assistance and getting me here yeah
love bro thank you so much Cheers Cheers